>> Male Presenter: All right.
Well, good afternoon everyone.
Thank you
for stopping by another Google talk.
We're very pleased
and honored to have with us today Chris Fedak
and Josh
Schwartz the co-creators and co-producers
of the hit NBC show Chuck hit..
>>Josh: Hit
>>Chris: Whoa
>> Josh: You guys can do anything at Google.
[laughter]
>> Male Presenter: Which is on its final season
this week.
For those of
you that are watching the archive footage,
our talk today will
cover spoilers up until the final three episodes
with the
last ones airing next week.
And we also solicited
questions on Google moderators.
So thank you to all the
fans who submitted some extra questions.
We'll get those in as well.
Chris and Josh what I wanted to start out
with is just
talk about the characters on Chuck.
That's one of the center
parts of the show is the character development
that's
happened over five seasons.
>>Josh: I'm Josh by the way.
That's Chris.
Just to clarify.
Well, I
think for us character was always the most
integral part
of the show.
By the way, should I be looking at the
camera or the room.
What's better for the –.
>> Male Presenter: You can look at the camera
be then you can like scan the room
>> Josh: Seduce the camera or just passing
glances?.
[laughter]
>> Male presenter: Well, you can make sure
everybody is.
>> Josh: Little wave, okay.
>> Josh: So yeah, for us character was always
kind of the most
integral element to the show.
Because obviously there was
this high concept of a show with a guy who
gets a computer downloaded in
his brain.
There was going to be action and there was
going to be all that kind of
fun.
But for us it was always a character story.
It was always the story of an
Underdog guy who felt like his whole life
-- he had all this
potential that he had never really fulfilled.
What do you do
when you are given the opportunity to finally
live up
to that potential?
The sort of outsider-underdog element to Chuck's
character.
For us the litmus test was always if you pull
out of the story a
guy gets a computer downloaded into his brain,
are these
still a group of characters you want to hang
out with.
And that was really the challenge we had for
ourselves in
starting out with the show.
Chuck's home life, his family
life, obviously the weirdos who work at the
Buy More.
All those people really wanting to feel like
these are
characters you want to hang with and see evolve
regardless
of what bad guys of the week they're dealing
with.
>> Chris: Absolutely.
I think the other thing, too, when we first
stat down to talk about this show, we were
all going
through that late quarter life crisis.
You're on the
cusp of being an actual legitimate adult.
I think Chuck
kind of echoes that in a way especially his
growth over the years.
We started off in season one as a guy who
didn't know
what he wanted to do with his life.
And, for each season
of the show, Chuck has changed from the guy
who didn't
know -- couldn't figure it out -- to figuring
he does want
to be a spy.
That evolution was something we did want to
track.
In a way being a spy echoed people being on
with
their lives at this point.
And that was a lot of fun.
>> Josh: We talk about your question evolution
of characters
over the series.
Obviously, you know, one of the biggest
things was Chuck's secret and as his friends
and the people in his life started
to find out about it and get pulled into that
world that would obviously have
a tremendous impact on Chuck.
But also on people like
Captain Awesome.
Nice T-shirt by the way.
>>Male Interviewer: Thank-you.
I came prepared.
>>Josh: Plug your T-shirt.
We did not give that to him.
He was wearing
that when we got here.
And Morgan and his sister Ellie.
So I think that was a key part of the show
when they have
that information leak out, when to have people
find out.
The other big thing obviously was the sort
of Chuck/Sarah
love story.
And as Chris said, at the beginning of the
show,
Chuck didn't know what he wanted to do.
But he had this
group of friends.
He had his family.
He had his
personal life pretty well figured out.
His professional
life not so much.
And Sarah was someone who was going to
come into his world who had her professional
life
completely figured out but had no personal
life.
And
actually, when we met her in the pilot, Bryce
Larkin was
her ex-lover, had just been murdered.
And you know she was
someone who was always kind of the kick ass
CIA agent who
never really had a family, never really had
friends.
Chuck was always going to be kind of envious
and excited
looking up to her world and Sarah was always
going to be
looking up to his world as well how nice it
would be just
to be a human and relax and have friends and
hangout.
And
so, watching Chuck kind of become more of
a bad ass spy
as you were saying and watching Sarah become
more human and reconnect
with her family, be okay with feelings and
having
emotions -- those were two of the main, I
think, kind of
character spines that ran through the show.
>>Chris: Absolutely.
I think the other thing too it's really
two people from two different TV shows running
into each
other wanting to be in each other's television
show.
So
it's always been a mash up in that way.
And I think that
because Sarah Walker should be the star of
the television
show in her own right.
>> Josh: And John Casey obviously thinks he
should be the star
of his own show.
>>Chris: Exactly.
[laughter]
>> Josh: He feels like that Jack Bauer guy
was a huge pussy.
If it had been John Casey on 24, it would
have gone 12 hours.
John Casey wouldn't need 24 hours.
[laughter]
>>Male Presenter: That's very shining.
>> Male Presenter: And also one thing I noticed
in the character
development was the relationship between Morgan
and Ellie
as well.
They started out as basically enemies with
Morgan as this creepy stalker person.
[Josh and Chris laugh] Towards the ends
Morgan came into his own as a mature adult.
>>Josh: He sure did
>> Josh: He grew into that beard.
That's for damn sure.
[laughter]
Somebody coming in.
Join us.
No, I think.
Morgan was
interesting.
We've actually done a little bit looking
back on Morgan because Josh Gomez is this
tremendously
likable guy, with a tremendously likable beard.
And we
always felt like he was going to be this great
comic
energy on the show and the first season people
really
hated him.
[chuckles]
>>Chris: They hated him
>>Josh: They're like who's this dip shit Morgan?
Hello.
>>Chris: And
Ooh -- that looks tasty.
>> Male #1: So good.
>> Josh: For us?
No.
And so, one of the things that we knew
we needed to work on after the first season
was how do we
get people to like Morgan as much as we like
Josh Gomez
and we knew people were going to like Morgan.
Part of
the issue was Morgan was always in the way.
It was like
Chuck was trying to go on a mission and bumbling
Morgan
was kind of stopping him from being able to
do that.
And
once Morgan started to get a little swagger
of his own.
Got to be
assistant of the bar manager which is, you
know, it's a
good way to feel your oats.
>> Chris: [laughing].
>> Josh: And be more like the Alfred to Chuck's
Batman.
That
became a role for Morgan that really allowed
Josh's comic
gifts to flourish and for the character to
really click
with the audiences.
>> Chris: But there's a real fear when you
work in TV especially
when somebody has a secret like Chuck's secret,
especially in these first
couple of seasons, was that the whole show
is dependent on
people not knowing.
I think one of the realizations we
had was the show kind of got better and better
the more
people who found out kind of became part of
the Carmichael
team.
It really started with Josh Gomez in season
3.
We
knew halfway through the season, I think episode
9, we are going to
have Josh found out.
>>Josh: Awesome found out.
>>Chris: Awesome found out at the end of the
season too and
that's great and it was fun.
>> Josh: I just make sure you've seen the
show.
[laughter]
>> Chris: I watch it from afar.
Yeah, and that was important.
That was a big part of why, you know, the
show -- we were
able to go for five seasons and 91 episodes
was because it
was fun to bring people into that world.
What was great
about Gomez was he was a fish out of water.
By that
point, you know, Chuck had become somewhat
knowledgeable,
somewhat good at being a spy, kind of good.
So Gomez was
our new guy.
Our new wide-eyed participant.
>> Josh: He became the new Chuck.
Also in terms of letting
people know about the secret.
We always thought we were
getting canceled.
So you know you're always like, well, we
could be getting canceled.
Somebody should find out
before we get canceled.
It'd be awesome.
Hey, we didn't get canceled.
Somebody else should get find out.
>> Male presenter: Then Jeff Found out everything.
>> Josh: Yeah with yeah.
Which we always joke from the
beginning is Jeff would find out everything
and then
forget the next day.
>> Chris: Which I think we did.
>> Josh: From the very beginning.
But actually a lot of people
didn't know when we first started working
on the show
Chris had this great idea at the time that
Captain Awesome was going
to turn out to be bad guy.
You were going to find out
later on he was like a spy he was planted
there.
He was
the enemy and the whole relationship with
Ellie had been
a fraud.
And I always thought that was super-cool.
That was a bomb we were going to drop at the
end of
season one.
And then, we cast Ryan McPartlin as Captain
Awesome and
everybody loved him from the get-go the first
time he said
'awesome'.
>> Chris: Three lines and you love the guy.
>>Josh: "Way to go; awesome" and people were
like I'm in with
that guy.
>> Chris: He's going to be the bad guy.
He can't do that.
>> Josh: We very quickly realized we should
not make one of our
most likable people the villain.
>>Male Presenter: Maintain that family.
>> Josh: Exactly.
And once Morgan got a love life of his own,
he became much less creepy to Ellie.
>>Chris: True.
True.
>>Male Presenter: And then also I really liked
the development that
happened with the minor characters, with Buy
More.
I was wondering--
>>Josh: I would not refer to them as minor
if they're watching
this at all.
[laughter]
>>Male Presenter: Well, for people like Fernando
and Skip
>> Josh: Oh, Fernando and Skip -- minor is
fine.
>>Male #2: [inaudible] Impromptu Jeffster!
performance?
>>Chris: No, no, that's gonna be scary
>> Josh: Tonight?
You will see Jeffster! again before the show
is done.
>>Chris: Yes, you will see them again
>>Josh: Yeah, those guys have been part of
the show for five
years and they get their due as well.
>> Chris: Yeah, they also get lines in the
final episode --
Fernando, Skip, and some of the guys from,
who have been in the Buy More back there will
actually have lines from the final
episode.
>>Chris: That's part of the discovery.
I think when we first
started working on the show, we shot our first
episode
the pilot was shot in CompUSA which was going
out of business.
So
we could only shoot in the middle of the night.
>> Josh: It was very sad.
>> Chris: Very sad.
Then when we built the Buy More, once we got
the pick
up, we built the actual stage.
We had to populate it with
people.
As the show went on, we started to write to
them
in the background.
So we would write to Fernando or to Skip
making sure we were always folding them into
the story in
odd ways even though they didn't say anything.
Always
kind of imagine they're having their own stories
back
there.
>> Josh: Yes Sarah's high school reunion when
there was the big rager at
the Buy More.
>>Chris: That's right
>> Josh: He got some on the couch.
>>Chris: He did get something on the couch
>>Josh But even in terms of Jeff and Lester,
who are the stars
of Chuck if you ask you know Jeff or Lester,
that when we
were shooting the pilot they didn't have much
to do in
that episode.
They had a couple of lines.
But they were
so weird and they had such an interesting
chemistry that
we were like we have to keep writing for these
people.
But when we tested the show, you always have
to test your
pilot, --the network and the studio do--,
people thought they
were the bad guys just based on three lines.
So we had
to work very hard to make them not become
the
super-villains.
>> Male presenter; I also want to transition
to the fan following, the cult following of
Chuck.
I think that was one thing that continued
and
grew from the Subway sandwiches to the campaigns
to the
napkins.
I wanted to ask how much attention did you
pay
to the fan revolution and will that affect
your future
work as well.
>> Josh: Oh, we 100 percent pay attention
to it.
I think we've
been very vocal in our gratitude towards our
fans and I
think our cast has done an amazing job of
any time the fans
have events those guys are -- every single
one of them is
there.
Everyone is so appreciative.
The fans really did
mobilize in a very unique and clever way.
You reference the
sandwiches.
100%; that was unheard of.
No one had eaten
sandwiches as a sign of protest before.
>> Chris: Just a savvy way.
Our fans have always done I mean
just like our fans have always been very clever
and smart
when it comes to -- you know, we've done product
integration.
The show started to latch on to that.
And
it was a great idea because it's great when
NBC is
deciding should they pick up the show or not
and the CFO
Subway is giving them a call, "hey, we like
that show
where we're getting all this kind of sandwich,
you know,
excitement about."
[laughter] It's like that's only a helpful
thing.
It just speaks to the savviness.
>>Josh: It's amazing that subway wanted to
stay in business
with us after Jeff revealed his sandwich of
choice was
the Tunaroni.
>>Chris: Oh yeah, that was amazing
>>Josh: Tuna and pepperoni.
That was Jeff's Subway sandwich.
You felt right there
Subway should have ended their relationship
with us.
[laughter]
>>Male presenter: Have some secret menu.
>> Josh: But it was a show for the fans.
I mean, we were fans
of the kind -- there were certain movies and
shows we
grew up on that inspired us and influenced
us.
I think there was kind of a
common language in the DNA of the show just
in terms of,
you know, the genre of the show, the tone
of the show,
the references that were built into the show,
episodes
inspired by things and guest stars that we
had on the show
that spoke to those things so there was a
common language
and lore that we had talking about the show
and it became
a conversation that extended to the fans.
The fans, you
know, I think loved the same references that
we did and
were excited about those same things and got
everything.
There was never an homage, never a guest star,
never anything
that the fans didn't pick up on and also appreciate
it
was part of the same conversation.
And I think ComiCon
was also a huge thing for the show.
Again, we were
very -- you know, we weren't necessarily high
on the
radar on NBC when we premiered.
I don't know that we've
ever been high on the radar at NBC.
But we got to ComiCon for the
first time and is it like anybody's going
to come to this
panel?
Does anyone care?
The room was full.
The show
got a standing ovation.
It was the greatest feeling in the
world.
I think we were hugging each other and we
do not
like to touch each other very, very often.
And the
following year we went back and the room was
bigger.
And
the following year Jeffster! performed.
It was like very
disturbing.
The euphoria people had for.
People were
taking their shirts off.
Mostly men.
[laughter] For them and they
were really -- you know, and so just having
that
opportunity.
When you make a TV show.
It's not like
making a movie when you get to sit back in
the theater
and watch the movie with the audience.
There's very few
opportunities where you get to watch the show
with an audience.
I think ComiCon, WonderCon, what's the one
in New
York?
ComiCon New York?
>>Chris: ComiCon New York.
>> Josh: Very creatively named.
[laughter] I think all of those
opportunities for us to get with the fans
and watch the
show with them and interact with them has
always been
tremendously rewarding.
>> Male presenter: It's something you can't
build either.
>> Josh: It's 100 percent organic.
You can't fake that.
Believe me if we could within we would have
tried.
But
it's something that just took on a life of
its own.
I
think we just kind of stood back and watched
as, you
know, it really took form and the network
had to acknowledge
it.
It could not be ignored.
They made a statement that
was very powerful on behalf of the show.
>> Chris: Absolutely.
I think that experience at ComiCon was
really a moment for us when we felt like we
had kind of
tapped into something in the sense Chuck,
Chuck the character, was a great way
to kind of bring people into this world, into
this show and to
meet these people.
And I remember by the point you got
to the end of the episode and you saw Casey
and Sarah at
the Buy More, you saw what this show was going
to be.
People were just really jazzed to see what
was going to
happen next.
For us that theatrical experience you just
don't get that.
Usually you send the show off; people people
watch it home and have
their own personal experience with it.
But the weird
thing about our show is, -- we found this
in San Francisco as
well--, it plays great with a theater.
Plays great with an
audience.
It's probably because we always designed it
in
a way as a little summer blockbuster each
week.
And
yeah.
>> Josh: So we're going to take the show on
the road now that it's over.
>>Chris: Exactly
>> Josh: Vaudeville production of Chuck.
>> Male presenter: In theaters.
On Broadway
>> Josh: Yes.
Exactly.
>>Male presenter: That would be cool.
I would go see it.
>>Chris: Season 6 on stage.
>> Josh: Yeah.
>> Male presenter: So transitioning.
>> Josh: Ice Capades.
[laughter]
>> Josh: Or Chuck-aPades.
>> Male presenter: Or an opera.
Just like dramatic opera.
>>Josh: Wow
>> Josh: Pavarotti as the new villain.
>>Chris: I can see Jeff and Lester right in
the middle
[laughter]
>>Male presenter: And also looking over across
the four seasons, five seasons I should
say yeah what would you say was your favorite
Chuck
moment across the episodes?
>> Chris: Thanks for that.
[laughter] Yeah, you know, it's for the life
of
me -- every episode in the show kind of turns
into a
child in a way.
Some of the loved a little bit, you know a
little less than others.
>>Josh: Some of them cuter than others
Chris: Some of them definitely cuter than
others.
But I
think that there's been some -- you know,
I think the
moment of Sarah and Chuck coming together
for the first
time in episode 13.
I think that there's an episode called
Chuck versus the Colonel.
These are all romantic almosts.
Over the years when we first started talking
about the
show.
I loved action movies and it's kind of what
I focus
on.
I've turned into a big softhearted romantic
turning
into Chuck..
>> Josh: That's what I did to Chris.
I was the teen soap guy and he was like girly
guy.
He
was John Casey.
[laughter]
>> Chris: Yeah, I walked around calling you
the girly guy.
Over the years I've found
those big romantic moments to be my favorite.
So
and Sarah and Chuck in the hotel room in the
Colonel episode making out in the bed.
It's
just like these great.
What you find in television it's
about relationships and I think that's something
we
didn't understand when we first got into the
show you
start working on a pilot it's very much like
a little movie, but
really television is about people and families
and those
interactions.
I think for me it's those big moments.
In
our finale we're going to have a couple of
moments that
are definitely, you know, some of the best
of the series
as well.
Because it's about the characters.
It's about
these people interrelating.
I think those Sarah-Chuck
moments are always my favorite.
>> Josh: I'd say yeah, the end of season 2
where the wedding and
Chevy Chase is marching through the wedding
and there's
paratroopers crashing through the Skylights
and Jeffster!'s
there performing and Chuck downloads the
new Intersect and suddenly knows kung fu.
I think for us
that had been something we'd wanted to do.
Even before season 1
but we couldn't because the writer strike
hit halfway through season one.
And so,
there was just so much anticipation and buildup.
the opportunity to do that and those episodes
really came
together.
It was also the last time we had any
money to make the show.
[laughter]
>> Chris: Season 2 was the end of the money.
But that was the
great moment.
We always said from the get-go our show is
not about some guy with super power.
It's not about a
guy with ability.
It's the computer only gives him
information.
And then, somewhere along the process Josh
was like what happens if we give him abilities?
And then
from that point on, that was a great way into
the second
part of the show which was Chuck wanting to
be a spy.
So
that moment was a huge moment for us.
It's like, you
know, can we pull it off and can Zach Levy
do it?
And he could we realized the show is possible
from that point out.
Zach Zach could do all these amazing spy skills.
>> Josh: There's also a moment in season 3
where Chuck and
Sarah are tied up or season 4 -- remind me.
It's all a
blur.
>> Chris: Which one?
Which one?
>>Josh: With
>>Male presenter: Oh with the battle like.
>> Josh: Where Dalton is standing over him.
Volkoff and Mary
are standing over him
>>Chris: Oh yeah, yeah
>>Josh: and we just looked at each other
it's like James Bond and Sarah Connor kicking
our
character's asses.
This is amazing.
[laughter] This is everything
we'd ever wanted when we were like 12-year-olds.
That was
pretty exciting.
>> Chris: Chuck versus First Flight, which
is one of our
best episodes.
I mean yeah, you work Timothy Dalton.
It's just super-amazing.
Because, you know, it's like he
takes that energy you see on screen, is like
that all the
time.
So Timothy would actually come to the writer's
offices and sit down with us and go through
the script
which is just amazing.
There's James Bond and he's
acting it out here in the office.
So we're like sorting
out the story.
It's amazing.
>> Male presenter: And also, looking at Google,
we have a big, I'd say a
cultural following and cultural resemblance
to the Buy
More.
We have our own nerd herd here.
>> Josh: Much nicer here from what little
I've seen.
>> Male presenter: And we focus a lot on really
designing great products
too.
Thinking about the Intersect one thing that
struck
my mind.
>> Josh: You guys building that here?
Can't talk about that I
understand.
[laughter]
>>Male presenter: I haven't been on the complete
tour in Los Angeles so
I can't answer that.
But there's other.
>>Josh: I understand
>> Chris: For those of you at home there's
a big cut right there.
Something was
just discussed and I'm just coming back into
the conversation.
>>Josh: We've been tranqed.
We've been reprogrammed.
>>Chris: But we're back>> Male presenter:
Back to the Intersect.
So what was the product
development life cycle like for the Intersect.
First it
was the thing.
>>Chris: Oh Jesus Christ
>>Josh: This is a Fedak question.
>>Chris: Aw geez.
Thanks a lot.
That's like a government question.
Yeah, thanks.
[Chris and Josh talk over each other]
>> Male presenter: Tips.
How do we get from killing a person to frosted
tips.
[laughter]
>>Chris: How do we get from killing a person
to frosted
tips.
I think the first one -- there's been a couple
different durations of the computer.
God I'm not going
to go through them because I need a flowchart.
>>Josh: If you put on these sunglasses, you
will get a
download.
>> Chris: Which also works much faster than
when Chuck first did
it.
But I think when we first talked about the
Intersect
it was something that we didn't quite know
what it could
do and how it could affect Chuck, but he was
somehow
perfect for it and in some ways chosen by
his father.
But
this season season 4 we thought about the
Intersect in a
different way in the sense we saw Shaw had
had uploaded
the Intersect into his head and it had a certain
affect.
But what would happen if the Intersect had
a different
effect on each person you brought in.
What if it was
more like the ring of power, you know?
What if you
actually made it into something that when
someone up
loaded the Intersect it would affect their
personality as
well.
And so, for Morgan, we thought wouldn't it
be great
to see Morgan as the Intersect and wouldn't
it be also
great if it turned him into a gigantic douche,
you know?
So
that was the thing that we began to think
about as season
4 is the Intersect is a scary thing that you
don't want
inside your head.
And maybe only one person can have it
inside their head and be able to handle it
and that's
Chuck Bartowski.
And he doesn't have it this year.
Always winds
up in somebody else.
So if it's not Morgan it's Shaw.
And now, as we see at the end of the last
episode it's in
Sarah's head.
And in these final couple of episodes we're
going to see what effect is on Sarah Walker.
>> Male presenter: Does she flash or zoom?
[laughter]
>> Chris: Well, she certainly flashes.
>> Josh: Whoa, Sarah Walker flashes.
That could really get
people to watch.
>>Chris: Yes, please.
[ laughter].
>> Male presenter: Nice.
Along those lines we had a question from FJed
85 from
YouTube.
Thanks for writing in.
He or she wanted to know the most dangerous
stunt Yvonne has ever done.
How about the rest of the
cast.
>>Josh: Well the most serious thing Yvonne
has almost done is
almost kissing Lester.
[laughter]
>>Chris: True
>>Josh: That was dangerous for both of
them.
>> Josh: I don't know Yvonne is such a sport.
I remember
Michael Clarke Duncan who's like 7 feet tall
and
outweighs her by several hundred pounds just
walloping her on top of
a rooftop.
That must have been pretty dangerous.
>> Chris: That was an amazing sequence.
They also had to wire
her for that sequence because he would hold
her up in the
air.
So she was up on the rooftop wired into a
rig.
>> Josh: She's fearless.
>> Chris: They're fearless.
Zach and Yvonne are -- it's amazing
what they will do.
In many of those instances when
you're watching something, it was actually
them doing it.
You know, the Thai fighting scene.
All those sequences
are what's amazing about them is just how
close they get.
It's like when they're working on a fight
sequence we
have an incredible stunt coordinator Merritt
Yohnka and he
can really get Zach Zach and Yvonne into those
sequences in a
very close and intimate way.
And it's an amazing group.
So it's very controlled.
It's very safe.
But it's.
>> Josh: Probably for Morgan his most dangerous
stunt is
>>Chris: walking anywhere.
>>Josh: Walking anywhere
>> Chris: He's Gomez.
[laughter]
>> Josh: In one season he was grabbed around
the throat by
former New York giants Michael Strahan and
then he was
line-drived to the ground by Jerome Bettis
AKA "the bus" formerly with the Steelers.
So I think we probably put him through the
ringer that
year.
>> Chris: That's probably it.
That's probably the most dangerous.
But for Zach, we
started season 3 I think no season 2 with
Zach hanging out
a window.
And that's Zach hanging out a window of a
downtown warehouse here in Los Angeles, six
stories up.
And it's one of those moments where you are
thinking to
yourself, "we're going to hang the star of
the show off
the side of the building."
And one -- Zach wants to do
it.
He's a director at heart so he wants the shot
to be
amazing.
And then 2 -- you have to trust your team.
You
have to know there's a bunch of invisible
things that are
protecting your crew, but it's -- it's still
six stories
up.
For me, it was -- I sat there the most nervous
person on the set.
>>Male presenter: Cool.
And we also like going back to fans paying
extra special attention to every nuanced detail.
So we
have a person.
>> Josh: That sounds like mistake -- finding
every mistake.
>>Male presenter: Jonas Life Ten says in the
pilot episode of Chuck every
time Chuck flashes he sees a picture of a
slice of pie.
>>Josh: Uh-huh.
>> Male presenter: Is there deep symbolism
in the pie or is the cake a lie
>> Chris: There was a lot of meanings on that.
>> Josh: There's a lot of pie meanings.
>>Chris: When we first started working on
the show, we were
trying to imagine how exactly the Intersect
would work.
And so, each episode would have a different
mission.
Would have a different set of flashes.
And each flash
would have an album cover.
And so, the apple pie was the
album cover.
>> Josh: And it would have an image that was
very innocuous,
very kind of nonthreatening.
And what's less threatening
than apple pie unless you're allergic to apples.
>>Chris: And so, there would be the apple
pie and then inside of
it would be all this spy data and then at
the very end of
it you would close it off with the apple pie.
And we did
that for the pilot.
And I don't know if we did it ever
again.
I don't know if we need that.
>> Josh: I think we tried.
I think there's always some weirdly innocuous
image at least in the beginning.
>> Chris: That's right.
At least there was a wall in the
editorial department which was filled with
these album
covers
>>Josh: --like a puppy, a baby, whatever it
was.
And that
inside that image, the mission was encoded.
And so, when
they're flashing, like Chris was saying, they're
opening the album cover and
playing the contents of the album which was
the mission.
>> Chris: Which would all link up to what
was downloaded in
Chuck's head in the pilot episode.
But once we got into
the spy abilities everything changed.
We came up with a
different format for that.
So that was the original
idea.
>>Male presenter: And in terms of names for
episodes does that come
early in the process?
How do you choose?
>>Josh: I think Chris named the first episode
Chuck versus the
Helicopter.
And then after that it was like let's just
go with
versus, every week.
So it became, it's always Chuck versus something.
>> Chris: That's right.
>> Josh: At the out set.
>> Male presenter: And one final question
I had on the plot is,
especially with the episodes in Chuck versus
the Baby
when some of the pre-story the origin story
of Chuck
shifted a little bit in terms of Sarah's involvement
and Bryce Larkin so forth.
Looking back in the series what's the
role for free will in the show like was Chuck
chosen?
>> Josh: We've debated that a lot.
Once you found out that,
you know, that his father had kind of, you
know, built it
for him and was kind of searching for him
and he was
searching for his dad without knowing it and
that he had
downloaded once when he was a child we definitely
had a lot of
debates about free will and was he selected.
Was he Luke Skywalker or was he Spiderman,
like Peter Parker.
Was he bitten by a random spider or was he
always meant to be a hero?
>>Chris: I think that for us especially going
into the show we
started as a Peter Parker story.
We started as the guy
there was a mistake.
The first versions of the pitch
it's like Bryce Larkin was trying to send
an e-mail to really
important spies.
>> Josh: The CIA but instead he was one letter
short.
So it
went to Chuck.
Chuck was right above CIA in his smart
phone.
>> Chris: But I think as the show went on
I think the mythology
we wanted to build up the family story because
we found
it was really a family story.
So we began to build it
along the lines of Luke Skywalker as opposed
to Peter
Parker there would be that the family would
have been in
some ways tangentially related to the spy
world and that
Chuck would be discovering more.
That was a realization
of the first six episodes from the pilot on.
We were
kind of seeing that there was going to be
a darker, deeper
world there.
>> Male presenter: Yeah, and even when the
decision comes to either kick
ass or save your family, Chuck's going to
save his family.
>>Josh: Every time.
>>Male presenter: That's pretty I think one
of the best messages of the
show.
>> Josh: Always save your family.
[laughter]
>> Josh: And then kick ass.
>> Male presenter: Does the show match what
you initially envisioned as
well when you first cast the pilot to writing
the final
episode, has your thoughts on the show changed.
>> Josh: Well, I think as Chris was saying
one of the great
things about television is you have the opportunity
to
continue to explore characters.
So obviously in your
head the pilot is a movie.
You want the movie to succeed well
enough to have a sequel.
You actually want 100
sequels -- that's the goal.
[laughter] And, but as you start to get
to know your actors better and you start to
kind of know
their voices and you know things evolve.
And I think
there's just a natural evolution to how the
series goes.
So I feel like it's still very true to where
we started
but yet it's kind of had all these great offshoots
and
tangents and characters that seem like supporting
characters getting huge storylines of their
own.
Romances failing and coming together.
John Casey's got a daughter and Morgan's dating
her.
Those are things that you know
are possibilities when you're first planting
those seeds
during the pilot but you really need to be
able to have
enough episodes to be able to let all that
stuff grow
evolve.
>> Chris: I think there are certain things
-- certain pillars --
we want to get to throughout the show.
One we wanted to
give Chuck's abilities at the end of season
2.
And then
this was also a thing which was metamorphosis
we wanted
to build the team.
We kind of had in idea of Carmichael Industries
at the end of season 3 that we wanted to put
into a motley team that would go out and get
into
trouble.
And we liked that idea.
So bringing people
into the spy world was kind of a part of it.
You're
right -- it's like discovery.
It's kind of like there's
a certain point when you're sitting in the
editing bay
and we're just like we got it.
We have to explore that more.
We have to figure out
that episode is.
And that's something you just don't know
until you see it.
>> Josh: Anybody who tells you who's done
a television show "I
had the entire series in my head" from the
pilot is lying.
Because you
can't.
Because there's just so many things you don't
know.
Characters are going to take off that you
didn't
expect.
Other characters you thought were, don't.
You lose an
actor because they're a recurring guest star.
Or they get
booked on another show.
Whatever -- there's so many
variables in the life of a series you have
to be able to
be flexible and run with what's working and
cut what's
not and make do if you lose somebody.
>>Chris: We have an actor, Mekenna Melvin,
that plays John Casey's daughter on
the show.
And the first episode that she appears in
she
has one line.
She was cast off the line "dad"!.
>> Josh: That's a good reading.
[laughter]
>> Chris: Thank you very much.
There's a point where the actors
actually act out the entire show.
It's not a pretty
thing -- the writers.
But when she was cast off that one
line.
When we brought her back into the show we
knew
that she was a very gifted actress but we
didn't know how
it's going to work out.
And it was one of those great
discoveries that she's fantastic.
She's not only
fantastic with Josh Gomez, but she has a great
relationship with her dad.
That's something that's
discovery this is an actor that we want to
write to.
>> Male presenter: And G 38 had a follow up
question.
>>Josh: I like your, [inaudible], G 38.
>>Male presenter: We only select the best
here on YouTube moderator.
Chris are you going to continue to cast on
the Scott Krinsky and
whatever future projects you do.
>>Chris: I very much hope so.
>> Josh: By the way can I tell the Scott Krinsky
story?
>>Chris: Please
>>Josh: Because I feel like, -- no offense
to what's his name G, 38--.
>>Male presenter: G 38
>>Josh: I'd like to take credit for Scott
Krinsky if I may.
In the OC --
the second to last episode, the show right
before Chuck was the show the OC, Scott Krinsky
played a
homeless man.
He actually showed up before Thanksgiving.
Summer Roberts became very altruistic decided
she was going to
homeless people come to the Cohen house for
Thanksgiving.
Scott
was amongst the homeless; I don't even know
if he had a line.
And you just look at that man's
face and you're like that man is a star.
In the
penultimate episode of the OC, there's a big
earthquake that hits Orange County.
Ryan Atwood is injured.
Seth Cohen
needs a car.
And their car breaks down.
He trades – Seth
Cohen runs into Scott Krinsky as homeless
man with a shopping cart and
trades him the Cohen Range Rover for the shopping
cart so he can
push Ryan to the hospital.
Okay.
Scott Krinsky ended up
with the Cohen Range Rover.
And then, when we were
casting the pilot, we had this -- again, they
weren't big parts and I said
to Chris I got a guy.
When you see his face you're going
to know this man is a star.
And I think you fell in love
almost as instantly.
>> Chris: Ah, it's an amazing face.
There's also a scene in the pilot where he
has to
wink.
He winks at Chuck and it's the strangest wink
that I've ever seen.
>>Josh: It was one eye if and then the other.
Very slow like
he was having a stroke.
>> Chris: It was an amazing wink.
So we were just like we had a
little bit of gold there.
He's a great guy to work with.
He's so much fun to write to.
>> Josh: And replicated in the Buy More unveil.
>>Chris: Exactly, yes.
[laughter]
>> Male presenter: So how do you keep track
of all the callbacks in the
series.
These recurring themes of sizzling shrimp
and Eiffel Tower.
Is there this huge dossier in your
studio waiting for little chestnuts to draw
out.
>>Chris: You mean callbacks to previous episodes
and stuff like
that.
>> Male Presenter: Yeah, yeah.
Like little homages.
>>Chris: So sizzling shrimp was something
that that was a early
episode.
It was a very challenging episode.
I think it
was one of the first episodes that we thought
we didn't
have enough show.
>> Josh: We also had a bad guy who was in
a wheelchair which we found
very early on was not that intimidating.
[laughter] He wasn't going to
do a lot of damage.
He was in Big Trouble with Little China.
We were excited about that.
That actor.
>> Chris: Right, right.
But so definitely we also brought it
back with the menu and whatnot.
I think once you have your
ninety-first episode you've built up a lot
of references
to your own show.
And so, you guys were kind of working
on the finale.
The finale is going to be designed as a
love letter to people who love the show.
And so,
there's going to be references to things we
haven't seen
in awhile.
And that's a fun part for us.
Also I think
that, if there's ever a chance to build out
the world of
your show.
We weirdly built a show world.
It's got its
own set of spies, its own box store in the
Buy More.
And
>>Josh: There's the Large
Mart.
There's the Buy More Beverly hills.
There's all
this stuff that's the mythology of the show.
>>Chris: And next week's
episode is our bullet train episode.
We also have this
whole sequence that plays in the Buy More
parking lot.
We shot it on the lot which of course looks
like a lot.
So our viz effects guy we have an amazing
team.
They go
in and they add the store signs in the background.
So for this episode, we're kind of
sitting there imagining the
Large Mart sign should be here.
It's a weird thing you
kind of know where those things are even though
we never
actually gone there.
You know the Large Mart is two
stores down from the Buy More.
>>Josh: Underpants Etcetera is right next
to it.
>>Chris: Exactly so we had to build up all
the backs of those
signs.
That was a fun part.
I'm glad in a weird way this is the very nerdiest
side of me we're building out that side of
the show.
It's
kind of like the spaceship in the what's -- Galaxy
Quest
where somebody actually knows where the engine
room is.
In the spaceship it's actually fun we've been
behind the
Large Mart sign in the Buy More Complex.
>> Male presenter: Cool, cool.
And you've also had quite a litany of
guest directors as well from Zach himself
to Robert Duncan McNeill.
>>Josh: He's our resident director.
He's been our producing
director on the show for five years.
>> Male presenter: Any anecdotes from working
with such a diverse crew
or?
Different styles that they bring.
>> Josh: I mean, the show is very director
driven.
Every
director that comes -- it's a very hard show.
Other
directors who have worked on the show calls
it a director
killer, because you don't have.
You have 7 days, you're doing
action, you're doing comedy, you're doing
romance, you're
doing, you know, coming of age stories with
real emotion.
There's always a sci-fi element at times.
So it's a really
tricky show.
And I think the directors that really
worked for the show were people that really
were able to
blend all of those genres.
>> Chris: It's kind of like the writers, too,
on our shows.
The
people that enjoyed comedy and genre.
You couldn't be
one or the other.
You couldn't be hard sci-fi on our
show and also enjoy it.
You had to be both.
You had to
enjoy both sides of it.
You had to enjoy the comedy as
well.
I think for guys like Robert who came from
the
sci-fi side, he really enjoyed the character
and the
drama side.
He enjoyed the comedy too.
>> Josh: And he directed like the Samantha
Who?
pilot.
He done a lot of
directing in comedies before.
We found we did better if we
had to choose guys who had comedy background
tended to be
better fits for the show tonally than people
who had done
CSI Palm Springs, because they just had like
those
guys -- it's a little bit more of a straight
ahead.
And
this show was never straight ahead.
>> Chris: Guys like Jay Chandrasekhar from
Broken Lizard.
Those are really
important directors to us.
Jeremiah Chechik.
Jason Ensler.
And I think that -- but it
was a show that we depended on our directors
to make it
cool.
I think a lot of shows have a house style
and you
know what that show is going to look like.
For the most
part looked the same.
We would always go to our directors, "we want
this to be the Muay Thai episode and they're
like what the
hell is that."
It has to be cool this way.
Or if we're going
to do like a Murder on the Orient Express
type episode we
want the train to be -- to evoke those old
movies we
love.
The lady vanishes.
So we really looked to our
directors to make it cool.
We were kind of
annoying in that way.
Make it hot or make it cool.
You
know?
And yeah –
>>Male presenter: We have question from Patricio
Rose in New York City.
If you had no budgetary limits, no scheduling
issues in
[laughter] this ultimate world what's one
story that you would have
loved to write for Team Bartowski besides
Jeff and Lester on the lam
which in itself is kind of cool.
>> Josh: Yeah.
I guess we implied that story.
>>Chris: We implied a
lot of stories.
>> Josh: There's a lot that happened off camera.
It's very
theatrical that way.
There's always been a big action
sequence happening just off camera.
Oh please.
>> Josh: No you go.
>> Chris: For the longest time we wanted to
do a ComiCon.
We
never could get the timing to work out because
ComiCon would actually let us in before they
allow people to film there.
But we wanted to do a ComiCon
episode where we had something like another
show Chuck and him and Morgan
having a mission there but also having other
shows that
they're interacting with.
We love the idea of
them being up on the stage as well as kind
of doing a spy
story.
>> Josh: I think, you know, for so often when
you go and you do
like Chuck goes to Paris or Chuck goes to
Rome and he
goes to the parking garage.
Or he goes to the basement
holding court.
>> Chris: Berlin alley.
>> Josh: The alley in Berlin.
The basement in Zürich.
So I
think to actually be able to go to one of
those exotic
locales and shoot there as opposed to shooting
in a
basement of a torture chamber allegedly set
there would
have been nice.
That little atmosphere.
>> Chris: The travel on the show would be
super-cool.
In the
future.
>> Josh: Chuck the Movie.
>> Chris: Chuck the Movie.
Yes.
>> Male presenter: Versus the silver screen.
I like it.
>> Josh: Chuck versus the unlimited budget.
[laughter]
>> Male presenter: And looking at the finale,
too.
To a certain extent
this is kind of like your third chance of
writing a
series finale.
>>Josh: It might be more than that
>> Chris: Hopefully we'll get it right this
time.
>>Male presenter: Yeah, I was gonna say
>>Josh: There's been
several series finales and the show has been
lucky enough to stay alive.
>>Male presenter: And we're proud of it.
Have you approached this one differently?
Were there
any things that you learned from the cliff
hangers in
your final seasons like your season 4, for
example.
>>Josh: Chris, you wrote it.
It's not a cliff hanger you
should say that.
>>Chris: It's not a cliff hanger.
I think the biggest thing we
learned going to this season is we want to
do an ending.
>> Josh: We knew we were told emphatically
this is it, guys.
We know
we told you that every year, but this is really
it.
We're done.
>>Chris: We were picked up and canceled in
the same
moment which is good in the sense we knew
we were going
to be writing the final chapter.
So when we sat down to
think about the ending, we really wanted this
to be a
final moment for the show.
In seasons, past Josh and I we
like endings that imply a great exciting next
chapter.
>> Josh: We ended the season 2 finale with
the words to be
continued and we had no idea if that was actually
true.
>> Chris: That was really a good chance we
were not coming back.
So that was kind of ballsy.
This would be a different
type ending and I think we definitely wanted
to structure
it in such a way that we haven't seen this
ending on a
Chuck show.
>> Male presenter: Cool.
And then, what was the final day of filming
like?
Were you surprised at things that made it
and
didn't make it on the cutting room floor.
>> Chris: It's amazing.
Josh missed the final but he had a
amazing excuse.
>>Josh: My wife's and my first child was born
on the last day of
Chuck.
She was literally born an hour before they
wrapped.
>> Chris: The facts incredible.
Because we were on-set.
It's
like the middle of the night and you know
we do the last
shot and it's very nice.
Kind of when you're on a film
set.
It's kind of nautical, that's not the right
word, but it's very procedural in
the sense that everybody has very specific
jobs so when
we wrap an episode when we wrap a character
the assistant
director announces that and he always does
that.
So as
we were kind of moving in on the final moments
of the
show, you know, it's the AD and the director
and myself and how
do we handle it.
And the AD will say this.
And the
director will say this and then I will say
something to
the cast.
And this is the procedure and it's the way
it's been done for ages.
And it was amazing in that
moment.
As I was going up to say thank you to the
cast.
It was a quiet moment in our castle set.
The crews were around.
We all
kind of gingerly.
We're all just talking to each other.
I'm thanking the cast and
I get an e-mail from Josh saying thank you
for the show.
It's been an amazing run.
And I'd also like to announce
the birth of Josh's daughter.
It was just a
amazing wonderful moment of things.
In some ways the Chuck show
has been a an incredibly tough process.
We never know
when we're going to be canceled.
And we've been lucky to
survive.
And I think that those wonderful warm little
moments
it was an amazing 5 years and I couldn't imagine
a better
way to top it.
>>Josh: Me either.
[laughter]
>> Male presenter: And do you think there's
room for a Chuck extended
universe like comics or a Jeffster CD
>> Josh: Jeffster's Greatest Hits, for sure
you'll see on like 3 in the morning after
like some sort of ab roller or ads.
I think we did a mini
run comic book at one point early in the show.
>> Chris: It was Chuck the movie.
Which actually we had pretty
much President Obama as the kidnapped person
even though.
>> Josh: In the comic book.
>> Chris: Even though he hadn't -- he wasn't
even nominated yet.
That was a lot of fun.
So yes -- I think we'd certainly
be open to the idea of an expanded universe
and the idea
there's people who would like to write fan
fiction about
Chuck is great.
>> Josh: And hopefully ten years somebody
will watch the show
will come down and say I got a great idea
for a movie.
That will be a nostalgia factor we'll wheel
ourselves up
and put in our teeth.
>> Chris: How old are we?
>>Josh: I don't know.
We're going to age badly is what I'm
implying.
[laughing]
>> Josh: Ten years we'll be 112.
>> Male presenter: Some time delay.
And of course if Jeffster wants to lay
down some tracks in Google music and that
sort of cuts
the distribution angle.
>> Josh: Wow, so everybody could have a piece
of those
nonprofits that we're not going to make.
>> Male presenter: What do you think the legacy
of Chuck is going to be
for future shows and for your own work?
>> Josh: I think, I mean, Chuck is a true
-- it gets harder and
harder and you guys know that just from seeing
what's on
TV.
It's harder and harder to make something that
is truly original
that's not already on TV, that's not based
on a comic book
or based on something that existed before.
And I think
what I'm really proud of about the show is
it was truly
something origin.
It wasn't something that had been on
the air before.
It was a brand new kind of collision of
genres and turned into something that took
a lot of
things that we certainly loved growing up
and fused it
into something new.
I think for people who ever felt
like an underdog, an outsider, there's a real
legacy
there.
He was a real hero for people.
To connect with
about the possibility for fulfilling your
potential.
I
think the relationship that the show had with
the fans is
also definitely part of its legacy and part
of its DNA.
And so, those are three things I can think
of I'm very
very proud of with the show.
>> Chris: And I think we're always amazed
when we're sitting in
the edit bay working on the show and it's
so unique.
The mash up
of -- you know, Josh brings amazing music
to the show.
And I think that it's such an incredible mash
up of music and
movies and TV and references that sometimes
we think it's
like we'll be lucky if they ever let us do
this again on
this scale.
So it's been a challenge, but it's been an
incredible opportunity to kind of smush all
these things
together and see what you get.
It started off like we
love shows from the 80s.
We love shows kind of classic television
shows like Quantum Leap and Magnum PI and
things we grew
up on.
This is a mash up of those things kind of
wholly
unique in a way especially in what it's trying
to do.
>> Josh: You know also Chris and I knew each
other from
college.
We never really worked together.
And so, to
have the opportunity to work together is also
something
that I really glad and grateful to have the
experience to
do.
>>Male presenter: Cool, are you guys planning
to work together in the
future.
>> Josh: We sure are.
>>Chris: We very much hope so.
I think that's also something I didn't know
how to
write a TV show.
It's like when Josh and I first sat
down I worked on features and those types
of stories.
I
think the amazing opportunity to work for
Josh allowed me
to kind of -- how do you write a big story?
How do you
write this crazy 91 chapters of some giant
weird novel called the
Chuck show?
Giant weird novel.
That was great.
Cut
that.
>> Male presenter: I think we have some time
for a few Googler questions
if there's any here in the audience.
We have a
microphone that we're passing around.
That way you can
be on the.
>>Male #3: First I just wanted to say thank
you for a really
entertaining five years.
My wife and I kind of find it
the most fun hour that we have with television
each week.
>>Josh: I would also say that we hear that
a lot from people.
It's fun.
It's an hour they can put on TV and enjoy
themselves have a smile on their face.
Families are able
to watch it together.
Stuff's falling out of my pocket.
And I think that's also something that we're
really proud
of for the show.
>> Male #3: It's been really fun.
I participated in the whole
Subway thing.
[inaudible] So my question is with the, you
know, I'm
really glad that you guys got a chance to
know this is
the ending this season.
Because I think you do finales
really well.
And I've very excited to see
>>Josh: And every 13 episodes we do one.
>> Male #3: Right.
So, but with that, you know, you've talked
a
lot about the character development and I
think that's
been a huge strength of the show and why it's
so fun.
But you know
having to wonder if you're going to be canceled
any
moment, with the character development that
you want to
do are there any real pacing challenges that
you've had
to deal with because you're not sure if you're
going to
be around next week and then all of a sudden
you found
out you had a reprieve.
>>Josh: 100 percent.
Chris is the guy who's living and
breathing in that writer's room and generating
stories.
And I remember like being able to walk into
his office
after they broke in episode 13 "great news
Chris, we just
got 11 more."
And him being like we got what?
[laughter] So you're
excited because your show is being picked
up and you're
going to get to make more episodes, but you
just came up
with the most amazing finale ever.
And now you got to
figure out how to have that be like a really
good episode
in the middle of the season and do like 11
more.
>> Chris: What happens next?
Yeah.
>> Josh: So it does.
I mean, I think part of what's always
driven show is this idea we don't want to
leave anything
on the table.
So there have been a lot of major plot
developments that have happened whether it's
people finding
out about Chuck's secret.
Obviously Chuck and Sarah got together near
the
end of season 2.
If we had known going into it that
season 3 was a lock, do you do that then?
I don't know.
I'm glad we did it.
It made for a really great episode.
But certainly it does inspire you to make
sure that,
"okay, what are some really major things we
know -- this
is it if we're walking off the court after
this, what do
we have that we've got to do right now?"
>> Chris: Yeah, I mean going back to season
one, we knew from
the get-go that we were going to bring Bryce
Larkin back.
We knew we were going have that story kind
of pop back in, but to bring Chuck and Sarah
back
especially with that relationship that part
we knew we
were going to do that.
But I don't think anybody thought
there was going to be an episode 7.
We waited 7 episodes
and we brought him back.
We thought that would have
been.
We realized early on especially in this day
and
age you got to keep telling the story.
>> Josh: You can't keep repeating the pilot
over and over.
>> Chris: It works for some shows but for
us we knew we had
to -- people were looking for mythology.
When we got to
episode 6 and we went to back to Stanford
there was a
real hunger for learning more about these
characters.
And I think at that point we were kind of
realizing it
wasn't a show that was just going to be episodes.
There
had to be a mythology.
>> Josh: Yeah.
I mean, the irony of season 1 was the one
season where we didn't get to do everything
we wanted to
because of the writer's strike.
So that was for us a
good lesson of, like, leave nothing behind.
Leave nothing
behind.
>> Male presenter: Any other questions?.
>> Male #4: So you were talking about how
the relationships are
really important.
And I know one of the reasons I really
enjoy the show is the family stuff that keeps
coming in.
And that's another way I keep liking these
-- as it keeps
going you kind of introduce new family.
I thought that
was really good.
>>Josh: Season 6 would have been Chuck's uncle.
Incredible.
>> Chris: We actually had an uncle for awhile.
>> Male #4: I actually was having trouble
coming up with a
question here.
>> Chris: Compliments are fine too.
We'll take those.
>> Josh: But we actually need those.
>> Chris: I guess.
Yeah..
>>Josh: No, it's always been big for us knowing
that Chuck's
mom was going to come into the show.
We pitched that to
NBC.
You can't cancel us.
Chuck's mom is coming and
we're going to get Madonna.
[laughter] And they're
like Madonna?
Great.
You're picked up.
And we're
like, "oh, shit.
How do we do that?"
And then,
obviously getting Linda Hamilton and somebody
who, again,
movies that we grew up on part of the mythology.
We knew
our fans grew occupy on that.
Who better represents the
like, the mother of all, you know, summer
movie
franchises block busters than Sarah Connor.
When we first
leaked that in comic on Chuck's mom is coming,
we were
like this is the little clip of her from Terminator
turning around.
It was just like for a second.
The
place went bananas.
And that was really fun.
And NBC
was like great -- where's Madonna?
Season 6 ma Donna.
>> Chis: I think just going off that.
The TV show especially
like Chuck even if it's not moms and dads,
there really
is a family, especially after.
>> Josh: Every show is about family.
>> Chris: Every show is about family and people
become a family
unit.
And I think that's what we loved about Chuck.
A lot of our favorite shows especially
sitcoms be it the Office or Cheers, much more
successful shows
than what we've done.
They're really about families.
They're really about people coming kind of
creating their
families these small units.
That's a great thing to
write.
>> Male presenter: We have time for one final
question.
>> Chris: All right.
>> Male #5: All right.
Mine's kind of trivial, but it's my
favorite thing I think from the show.
Who is responsible
for all of the Spies like Us references like
did GLG-20
Listening Device and the Emmett Milbarge those
types of things.
>> Josh: Well, look that was -- again, when
you talk about
movies when we talk about Spies Like Us was
a big one
because obviously was a spy story it but was
a comedy.
Chevy chase came on the show as a major villain.
Fletch
also big influence on the show.
We had a bunch of
writers who shared the same references.
>> Chris: And when we start working on something,
we usually --
we start talking about like stories and ideas,
but we
also talk about tone.
And the way we do that is we start
passing back lists of different movies.
This is part of
what Josh -- it was a really clever idea that
Josh had.
We can start passing these movies back and
forth and
there would be movies we'd take off the list
because they weren't one way or the other,
they were too dark.
But Spies Like Us always on the Chuck
list from the get-go.
It was always Spies Like Us.
There
was always.
>> Josh: North by Northwest.
>> Chris: North by Northwest.
And.
>> Josh: Which have never been mentioned in
the same sentence
before until now.
[laughter]
>> Chris: But pretty much the entire John
Landis cannon.
But
yes, Spies Like Us, incredibly important to
the show..
>> Josh: Good catch.
>>Chris: Emmett Milbarge
>> Josh: Milbarge met a very unfortunate end.
He was shot with Wilson Phillips playing in
the background.
We always
talked about bringing Tony Hale's brother
back.
His twin
brother who was like convinced that Emmett
Milbarge had
been killed and he would wear an eye patch.
>> Chris: We wanted to do that.
>> Josh: Just have Tony Hale in an eye patch.
>> Chris: Tony Hale is so cool, so great.
If we really, really like
somebody, we killed them.
Scott Bakula, Tony Hale.
Just
two amazing actors who were delightful to
work with.
Cold blooded.
We would kill them.
Shoot them.
>>Josh: Murdered.
Murdered.
That's our legacy.
>>Chris: That's our legacy.
>>Josh: If we like you, we kill you.
>> Chris: If we like you, we kill you.
>>Chris: If we don't like you, please stick
around.
>> Male presenter: With that I want to draw
everyone's attention to the
final three episodes of Chuck going on the
next two
weeks.
Then we'll have the --
>>Josh: Two hour finale.
>> Male presenter: Two hour finale.
>> Male presenter: Blue ray coming pretty
soon hopefully and then maybe
some sort of box set with complete director
comedy who
knows.
>>Josh: We should get on that
>> Chris: I like that.
>> Josh: We'll even use this interview make
it an extra.
>> Josh: You could be on it.
>> Male presenter: It would be an interview
within the interview.
So
with that on behalf of Google and on behalf
of the Chuck
fans everywhere thank you for really keeping
us
entertained for the past five years and thank
you for
stopping by the nerd herd at Google.
Thank-you very much.
>>Josh: Thank-you
>>Chris: Thank-you
>>Josh: Thank-you guys
[Applause]
>>Male presenter: All right, that's it
>>Josh: Good stuff